a delay in the trial of former  minneapolis police officer derek chavin  he is the officer accused of murder in  the death of george floyd last summer  video of course of the encounter with  shows chavin's knee firmly pressed into  floyd's neck as he shouts he can't  breathe  jury selection was supposed to start  this morning however a ruling to  reinstate a third degree murder charge  is still in the works and that is  delaying things a bit  demonstrators gathered outside the  courthouse this morning  demanding justice but many are doubtful  they're going to see it  i'm skeptical just because you know  history shows but you know i'm going to  try my best to  show support and hopefully they'll do  the right thing a lot of the times with  cases like this  there isn't really justice served chaven  has pleaded not guilty to charges of  second degree murder and manslaughter  jurors will now be questioned tomorrow